he's back thought such a little actually
you should make like just two little
like yellow marbles or seven put his
eyes ah yeah okay that's but first Nazi
joke I've ever made on the site isn't
that incredible so he'll let them do you
make Nazi Jim I need your friends huh
and what a shock Naruto is like been
sleeping up there an ounce and he's like
camera okay and comes on down but we're
not gonna be distracted I understand we
are going to talk about in your
footsteps not a sequel to the last
episode very very disappointing and
because we're ignoring him he's gonna
try and make even more of an appearance
but it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work evil kit iam doom
don't give me that look I'm gonna keep
going on that's right good talk to you
the audience because you're more
important big guys look at you your
audience talk about in your footsteps
this is about Finn and Jake they come
across a bear place a thing for this or
a single white female Sena and Jason
leaves leaves me alone with the kitty
now you look at the camera just trying
to totally get all the most meat yep
and I don't want to sit here for another
20 minutes listen to you babble about
nothing okay so they come across a bear
who and they saved the bear too and it's
all shit doggies gonna come back no
continuing oh your kid did you give
birth to the kitty yes
that's fine he's my cat shall I kick him
or anything children yeah not season
Charlie Sheen jokes Mike Mike humor is
so current okay so let's talk about bad
because so while they're out they find
this bear who ends up wanting to pretty
much copy and emulate everything that
Ben does and he saves him with the bun -
so he no no no I think you're you were
doing it wonderfully so they go back to
the house and that's when it really
starts getting a bit more bizarre
I like your actual comparison to single
a female that's the first thing pop -
Mike - L honestly didn't even think of
that but that's a great comparison it's
like holy shit yeah but yeah the bear
starts dressing and acting and even
talking like thin and - the blue flare
up he sets up a party and Finn and Jake
show up and the whole time cake is not
like the bear because well he's more
like he's taking the place of Jake yeah
yeah so there's this big party going on
set up by the bear and Jake let's been
known explains to Finn that he's
replacing it and so Finn gets pissed off
goes over against off the mask and says
this you know this is it don't worry the
imposter is gone everyone's like well
duh we knew it was a bear we're not
idiots
and then there's Jake in the background
he goes yeah I'm here so he Jake and
Finn go find the bear and say you know
we apologize and the Bears like I just
want to be a hero so Finn gives him the
enchiridion and the bear takes it to the
snail which is possessed by the Lich he
says everything's going according
nor something along those lines so
what'd you think uh I liked it I was the
same to myself at the ending this is
gonna go one of two directions either
he's going to cuz I was trying to
remember again let's try to go back this
story I'm like yeah the book defeated
the big demon that's now on the snail
right so I'm like okay so this has to go
either he gives it he was working for
the snail the whole time or he's gonna
go he's gonna come back in another
episode it's just gonna be like this
incredible hero he's just be perfect
English the best thing you ever did was
give me that book and I I thought that
little bit of good returning gag but I
like this though they're obviously
taking in this direction where the
snails gonna get you know more power
again the snitch Lynch Lynch Lynch if I
hit Ron Winstone
so the snitch gets the power from this
book again we rainbow the bridge yes
okay your britches I think you're wrong
about that one because I think what you
said before it doesn't tie into what you
just said now freak get the bitches okay
with that so the bitch gets the book you
know ain't now gonna become all-powerful
and stuff wow you're a boy okay we're
gonna keep focused ah see I'm keeping
focus but keeping the Canada was
distracting me by keeping your focus um
so so so they go um and I think the
thing with the bear that made me laugh
the heart is is Lee's trying to imitate
it because he is so clean you know
Finn's not very big you know he's a
little boy and everything and this
this bear is obviously gigantic
that was like sounds like hunger days to
like go ahead okay okay so it but that
belfry the funniest part to me as I love
okay works but no I thought was fine I
thought the funny scene is when he
actually has like the I love it I love
how tight the shirt is on ma he doesn't
get a bigger one I love the lame paper
mask in front of it I love the fact that
when you look at the grand scheme of
this plan it's ridiculous and there's no
way it can work they somehow ends up
working to get this block well actually
you know why Finn is that welcoming in
that loving you'd use the bear that kind
of wants to be like oh cool
I totally want something like that like
a strokes his ego to which I like you
know yeah he wants to be like me what's
wrong with that at the end of course
he's gonna sit there be like man I was a
total ass you know what does bring up a
good play why the hell did they never
use this book for anything it's like
this incredible holy crap for just only
use it to get away from grass or what
yeah like during the it's the only way
another way you sit there reading it
does he uh every once in a while account
pops up background but it's like because
that's where he found the monster of the
tear who's in the end karidian but he
makes a good point it's like yeah we
never really use it just kind of sits
there and I mean he's probably been
reading it consistently so yeah he's
probably right in a couple days so yeah
oh my god so yeah I mean I love like
that poncho if he comes back a hero at
the same time I like you know like ooh
where's this going like well they got to
of this I love the fact the bear just
got a bike and he can write it five
I love the music so um and I like how
how this one started - he's like really
doing it again he's like yeah it's just
falling it how did he get that high and
out of Jake well though Jake was in the
backpack that's right but how do you get
so high and comedy do it again yeah take
it to go that high so uh I thought was
fun you know it's a good segue into
whatever this story's gonna amount to
you know obviously building up to
something bigger but yeah perfectly
serviceable with a few good laughs good
times bring the whole family I don't